in 2022 every single murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist
every single murder in America was
committed by a right-wing every single
politically motivated murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist are
you sure about that are you are you
aware that the Tennessee shooter just
recently identified as a man and she was
a biological woman was she a right-wing
extremist as well young lady time is
expired to allow the witness to answer
the question so that was a shooting that
happened in 2023
there is no evidence as to what ideology
motivated that shooting we know the
identity of the individual as being
trans but as far as I've seen we
actually don't know the motivations and
just because you're trans doesn't mean
that the motivations were left-wing
motivations if they were I will
absolutely tell you it wouldn't change
the reality that overwhelmingly
politically motivated shootings in the
United States are committed by right
Wingers